kem sokha gets ready to defend himself
in court the leader of the noun
dissolved main opposition party is
charged with treason and could be jailed
for up to 30 years if found guilty
yosaku end of Charmian I know clearly
that I am innocent so I have to go to
court to challenge the charges and
demand they drop the case
Sokka was arrested in 2017 he spent
around a year in prison and then more
than a year under house arrest he was
released in November but banned from
taking part in politics and from leaving
the country the charges against soccer
stem from a remark he made seven years
ago about consulting American democracy
advocates on how to win in an election
two months after his arrest the Supreme
Court dissolved the Cambodian national
rescue party that he led and the ruling
party went on to win all the
parliamentary seats in the 2018 general
election the US the EU and some members
of parliament from around the region
have urged Cambodia to drop the charges
against soccer the EU is also reviewing
whether to continue extending
preferential trade treatment to Cambodia
a lawyer for the government denies
allegations that the charges against
soccer are politically motivated we as
lawyers for the government as well as
representatives of the prosecution
office we have plenty of evidence to
prove to the judges the wrongdoings of
kem sokha before the trial began some
were questioning how transparent the
proceedings would be foreign embassy
representatives and politicians are
allowed into the courtroom but the media
civil society groups and the public have
been shut out the case against soccer
has also had a wider impact beyond
politics in the country the chilling
effect on civil society space
where the freedom of expression we have
the freedom of assembly
we had the freedom of association happen
narrow become narrower and narrower and
these have also you know led many civil
society in a lambo and also it increased
more self-censorship many opposition
politicians have fled Cambodia some have
been prosecuted and others fear arrest
and some human rights groups say the
trial is a sham and a means for the
ruling party led by Prime Minister whom
sin to extend its grip on power
Florence gluey al-jazeera / Phnom Penh